pour faire céder vladimir poutine
l'union européenne dégaine une nouvelle
arme à sa disposition c'est le nerf de
la guerre l'argent bien sûr la
commission européenne propose un embargo
progressif sur le pétrole russe avant de
retrouver notre correspondante à
bruxelles on écoute ou sous la forme des
layènes
nous ferons en sorte que cet embargo se
fasse de manière progressive afin que
les lions le temps avec nos partenaires
de mettre en place des alternatives et
en même temps en faisant très attention
à minimiser l'impact sur le marché
global c'est pourquoi nous allons
arrêter les achats de pétrole brut six 6
mois et les produits raffinés d'ici la
fin de l'année
ainsi maxime ils ont la pression sur la
russie iran même temps et c'est
important nous lisons le dommage
collatéral pour nous et pour nos
partenaires à travers le monde pour
aider l'ukraine je nous devons nous
assurer que notre économie
bonjour alix le bourg dont vous êtes la
correspondante de france 24 dans la
capitale de l'europe dans le détail que
contient cette proposition d'embargo
progressif on le rappelle sur le pétrole
russe
et d'écouter d'abord cette proposition
de sixième train sanction a été
difficile à boucler pour la commission
européenne il ya eu beaucoup de
discussions avec plusieurs pays
européens qui craignent cet embargo sur
le pétrole russe comme notamment la
hongrie et la slovaquie qui sont deux
pays enclavé qui ne disposent pas de
porc et qui n'ont accès qu'à un oléoduc
rue saint mais justement cette
proposition de la commission européenne
prévoit un arrêt progressif des achats
européen de pétrole russe d'ici la fin
de l'année mais avec des exemptions
justement pour ces deux pays qui
pourront continuer leurs achats en 2023
le problème c'est que d'autres pays
européens aurait également aimé
bénéficier de telles dérogations comme
la bulgarie et la république tchèque
autre mesure contenue dans cette
proposition c l'exclusion de trois
banques russes supplémentaire du système
swift dont la sberbank qui est le plus
gros établissement du pays et qui
représente quand même 37% du marché
énergétique ce qui va renforcer l'
isolement total de la russie d'après
oursoul à von der leyen la présidente de
la commission européenne je vous
rappelle que sept banques russes sont
déjà visés par des sanctions européennes
alix on l'a bien compris en vous
entendant la proposition est donc sur la
table des européens manquent désormais
une étape et pas des moindres l'accord
des 27 l'unanimité est nécessaire
c'est en effet désormais au tour des
états membres de donner leur feu vert à
cette proposition de la commission
européenne et le texte va se retrouver
dès aujourd'hui sur la table des 27
ambassadeurs alors vous l'avez dit
l'unanimité est nécessaire jusqu'à
présent l'allemagne était plutôt
réticente à cette idée d'un embargo sur
le pétrole russe mais récemment et bien
le pays a levé ses réserves puisque
l'allemagne a réussi à réduire de deux
tiers la part de pétrole russe dans ses
importations mais on l'a vu c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué pour d'autres
pays européens comme la hongrie et la
slovaquie alors on verra si les
dérogations accordées dans cette
proposition de la commission européenne
suffiront à ces deux pays en vous le
savez la hongrie a menacé en début de
semaine de mettre son veto à toute
proposition d'un embargo sur le gaz ou
sur le pétrole russe on verra si les
solutions trouvées par la commission
européenne dans cette proposition
permettent d'éviter le véto hongrois le
premier ministre hongrois viktor orban
n'étant vous le savez un proche de
vladimir poutine